Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
La Chine est mon domaine depuis longtemps.
Un jour, croyant me faire plaisir,
quelqu’un m’a offert
cette boîte de chocolats.
[Yin-Yang de Suchard]
Oui, vous avez bien lu.
« Les opposés complémentaires. »
« Le bien et le mal. »
Bref,
l’emblème majeur de la pensée chinoise
est rapetissé à une nomenclature
d’antagonismes moralisateurs.
Non, Yin Yang n’est pas
une répartition figée.
C’est un modèle stratégique
de gestion du changement
que l’esprit chinois a lentement construit
à partir de l’observation fine
du fonctionnement des systèmes vivants
et des systèmes naturels.
Yin Yang, c’est un seul mot
qui, comme beaucoup de mots en chinois,
s’écrit avec deux idéogrammes.
Vous les avez là en grand
en écriture traditionnelle,
en petit en écriture simplifiée.
Traduire Yin Yang par le yin et le yang,
c’est-à-dire deux trucs séparés,
c’est en fausser la signification
et en bloquer la compréhension.
Le mot Yin Yang a deux significations,
l’une statique, l’autre dynamique.
La partie statique, on peut la lire dans -
Les deux idéogrammes
ont chacun une partie commune,
cette espèce de b à longue queue
qui, à l’origine, représentait
les édifices rituels
qui étaient strictement agencés
selon l’axe Nord-Sud,
et qui explique le sens
le plus archaïque de Yin Yang :
adret, ubac.
Adret, le côté de la montagne
exposé au sud, là où ça arde.
Ubac, le côté de la montagne
exposé au nord,
là où l’accumulation des nuages
rend le ciel opaque.
Opaque - ubac,
c’était le même mot au Moyen Âge.
Et de cette partie commune, on en tire
une première indication essentielle :
on ne peut pas penser
isolément yin ou yang.
Il ne peut pas y avoir d’adret sans ubac
comme il ne peut pas y avoir
de nuit sans jour.
La partie dynamique,
c’est la partie droite de chacun des deux
idéogrammes qui va nous l’expliquer
et nous apprendre que la dynamique
Yin Yang est une dynamique alternante.
Yin décrit un ciel s’obscurcissant.
Yang décrit un ciel s’éclaircissant.
C’est-à-dire que, à eux deux,
ils décrivent des épisodes consécutifs.
Un début d'orage, une fin d'orage.
Début d’orage - [fin d’orage],
comme jour - nuit,
comme Yin Yang,
ne sont opposés que lorsqu’on les isole.
Dans la vie,
ils alternent continuellement.
C’est pourquoi les assimiler
à des catégories figées,
pire genrées,
est un non-sens
aussi désolant que répandu.
Il y a un philosophe chinois,
un lettré chinois du 3ᵉ siècle,
qui a donné cette excellente
définition de Yin Yang.
[Yin, c’est ce qui va devenir Yang
Yang, c’est ce qui va devenir Yin.]
Et ça ouvre
des perspectives intéressantes.
Par exemple, si on applique
cette perception de Yin Yang
au cycle annuel,
alors, on s’aperçoit
d’une chose assez curieuse :
l’été commence le 22 décembre.
Eh oui ! Puisqu’à partir de cette date,
la durée du jour va se mettre à croître.
Alors évidemment,
inversement, l’hiver commence le 22 juin,
puisqu’à partir de cette date, la durée
de la nuit va se mettre à croître.
Oui, mais seulement, je vous assure,
s’apercevoir que l’été commence
le 22 décembre, ça aide à passer l’hiver.
(Rires)
Et puis s’apercevoir que
l’hiver commence le 22 juin,
eh bien, ça aide à profiter de l’été.
Alors si le concept Yin Yang
est né sous la forme idéographique
qu’on vient de voir
il y a à peu près 3 000 ans,
il n’a reçu de représentation graphique
que deux mille ans plus tard,
sous la dynastie des Song,
au 12ᵉ siècle de notre ère.
C’est ce dessin que vous avez dû
déjà certainement voir.
Taijitu, c’est son nom en chinois.
« Tu », le dessin « tai »,
du grand, « ji », retournement.
L’idéogramme « ji »,
le sens littéral de l’idéogramme « ji »,
c’est la poutre faîtière.
Mais dans l’architecture chinoise,
la poutre faîtière n’est pas sous le toit,
elle est au-dessus de l’arête du toit.
C’est pour cela que pour l’œil,
elle représente l’endroit où la pente
du toit, qui jusque-là montait,
se retourne et redescend de l’autre côté.
D’où l’idée de l’appeler
« le dessin du grand retournement ».
Les Jésuites, quand ils sont
arrivés en Chine au 17ᵉ siècle,
ils ont appelé ce dessin
le « faîte suprême ».
Peut-être pour tenter
de l’assimiler subrepticement
à l’idée du Dieu créateur
qu’ils apportaient aux Chinois.
Mais, vous voyez, trois siècles après,
le truc marche encore,
comme le montre cet extrait
du Larousse du 20ᵉ siècle, édité en 1931 :
« Principe premier, grand absolu » -
et avec des majuscules, je vous prie.
Bon.
En fait, la première chose, l’idée,
c’est que le système Yin Yang
est un système animé
par une dynamique interne.
Le point noir dans la partie blanche,
le point blanc dans la partie noire,
en fait, ce sont des graines
qui vont grossir
tout au long de la durée de la situation.
On voit dans ce dessin qui est
une création d’un polytechnicien,
M. Jean Marolleau,
on voit la petite goutte noire grandir,
la petite goutte blanche grandir,
mais cela ne modifie pas
la structure générale de la figure.
Sauf qu’à partir du sixième stade,
on voit bien qu’il va falloir un
accroissement delta pour que - tchac ! -
l’architecture entière
se retourne d’un coup.
Donc, ce que ce dessin nous montre,
c’est le premier grand principe Yin Yang :
le rythme du changement.
C’est : lente maturation,
brusque mutation.
Il y a un autre principe, qui est :
« Toute chose qui est parvenue à son
maximum se transforme en son compère. »
Oui, oui, j’ai dit « compère »,
pas « contraire ».
Parce qu'ils sont toujours ensemble.
Ceci est une animation
qui va vous faire voir
le même cheminement que celui
qu’on a vu précédemment,
sauf que là, tous les stades
de grossissement
sont les uns au-dessus des autres.
Il ne faut pas la regarder trop longtemps
parce que ça devient hypnotique.
Toutes ces images, c’est bien joli, mais
à quoi ça peut nous servir, Yin Yang ?
Eh bien, à plusieurs choses.
En particulier, si on les utilise
avec des verbes,
vous pouvez l’utiliser d’abord
pour apprendre à penser par deux :
dans chaque situation,
il y a toujours deux stratégies possibles.
Par exemple, dans une négociation,
qu’elle soit commerciale ou diplomatique,
il y a toujours des moments
où il faut être Yang - ferme -
et des moments
où il faut être Yin - souple.
Mao Tsé Toung,
qui, comme tout Chinois,
pensait Yin Yang -
il ne pouvait pas le dire
parce que ça faisait vieux jeu -
a inventé une formule choc :
« yi fen wei er » : un se divise en deux.
Il ajoutait : « Toute situation se divise
en une contradiction principale
et une contradiction secondaire.
Au cours du temps, la contradiction
principale deviendra secondaire
et la contradiction secondaire
deviendra principale. »
Yin Yang, ça peut nous servir à gérer
le changement d’une manière évolutive,
c’est-à-dire qu’il ne faut pas
appliquer le même type d’énergie
au lancement d’un projet
et à son accomplissement.
C’est un vieux proverbe chinois
qui explique ça très bien :
« Yang sheng, Yin cheng. »
Vous avez vu ?
(Rires)
« Le Yang enclenche,
le Yin mène à terme. »
Ce n'est pas le même genre de boulot.
Par exemple, il y a une dizaine de jours,
le Parlement européen a voté
une loi interdisant la vente des voitures
à moteur thermique en 2035.
C’est l’enclenchement - Yang -
par la fermeté d’une loi.
Mais ce jour-là, rien n’a
changé dans les usines.
Par contre, à partir de ce jour-là,
l’Union européenne a treize ans
pour essayer de reconvertir
les millions d’emplois
de gens qui travaillent
dans l’industrie automobile thermique.
Enfin, au niveau des relations humaines,
qu’elles soient familiales
ou qu’elles soient amoureuses,
Yin Yang nous rappelle que tout couple
est toujours un couplage Yin Yang
et que cela est complètement indifférent
aux sexes et aux genres.
Cette perspective permet,
dans tout type de relations,
de passer du duel au duo.
(Applaudissements)